welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast i'm your host hisham azuz and
this week i was joined by ben hobday ben
has been on a fantastic recruitment
journey for the last 12 years he's
worked for austin fraser and before that
he worked for hayes what we uncovered in
this episode really was we dug deep into
leadership ben has been on a really
interesting journey going from just
being an individual contributor to
becoming one of the best leaders within
the brand that he works for so if you're
anyone that's aspiring to be a leader
you're currently on that leadership
journey you're gonna absolutely love
this episode full of practical advice
and tips on how you can become a better
leader so enjoy this episode ben hob day
welcome to the podcast thank you for
having me
excited for this obviously uh
intended to have you at the live podcast
yeah but nature nature got in the way
yeah in a positive way absolutely so
little one came all okay yeah a little
bit early but um yeah it's all good and
here we are today so uh
where we always like to start is
particularly with someone in in the
position you're in now on the journey
that you've been on
probably just something that you've
you've thought a lot about so i'd love
to hear your take on
like what does ben believe are the
characteristics and traits of like a
really high performing recruiter in
today's market
yeah um
i think
for me i look at skills and behaviors
right so for me
things like integrity all those things
are really important i think a lot of
recruitment businesses look for
passion determination resilience i think
they're a kind of prerequisite like for
me i look for emotional intelligence are
you coachable um
can you spark conversation can you tell
a story um
we're here to solve problems right so
are you a good problem solver um
emotional intelligence is like massive
yeah can you read a room um those kind
of things and i think um
[Music]
it's it's easy just to look at someone
who's hard-working yeah yeah but if you
can't learn from a situation it's gonna
be very difficult so
typically they're the things like
coachability for me is massive um can
you learn so when when can you on the
coachability thing i love that
when can you what are the things to look
out for when you like maybe early signs
of light um this person isn't maybe
willing to
listen or at least take on other people
like what what have been the common like
key indicators
you think
definitely can you take feedback
like that's like a massive one if you
can't take feedback i mean you're gonna
get nowhere right so i think
constructive feedback um learning from
it asking questions on the feedback if
someone just goes yeah yeah yeah and it
does the same mistake they obviously
don't understand right so you've got to
be able to seek to understand take that
feedback and it's recruitment's
continuous improvement like that's
that's all we're trying to do find a
better way so
yeah do they listen do they ask
questions off the back of feedback yeah
and how they react to it yeah do you
think you can make someone more
coachable
definitely because i think i'm an
example of uh really yeah 100 um
i was quite hell bent on working really
really hard and just working hard on
everyone else when i first joined yeah
um
it wasn't that i wasn't coachable i
probably didn't listen enough right um
and
you know i'm a prime example of you know
someone who probably didn't
didn't take it quite so quickly i love
that so who so obviously you spent a lot
of your career at austin frozen yeah and
then before that you was at hayes yeah
right
who was uh who was ben before
recruitment
yeah so um i was a personal trainer
basically was it yeah yes classic
personal trainer or it's normally a
estate agent or a personal trainer um
yeah personal trainer
um you know very average at school to be
completely honest um
didn't really apply myself outside of
sports got a job in the gym because my
friends did yeah and then really kind of
realized i needed to get a real job
because hanging out in the gym all day
is pretty easy um but it's not going to
pay the bills it's hard though like you
got this i feel like i've had friends
that have like it's a sales job yeah but
sometimes people miss agreed i think
that's why it was a nice transition into
recruitment but if you're selling your
services you know you're doing that all
the time but i think
for me it was just at the point where
everyone wanted to start being a
personal trainer right okay so i kind of
just bailed bailed out of it really yeah
so who he sold like how did you how did
you stumbled into recruitment did you
have the classic story of like one of my
clients used to be a recruiter they told
me about it because we've had that a few
times yeah it's just basically a friend
a friend
i'm doing recruitment i used to work in
a gym it's talking to people all the
time give it a go i went to one
interview got the job and straight away
i was like yeah this is a this is for me
so did you start in construction yeah
what was that like
people ask me all the time in interviews
like it's a different world like this
was like the typical job title
i was doing labourers um bricklayers
carpenters so
you know like real
real challenging jobs and you know on a
monday if it was raining people just
wouldn't go to work so i'd spend the
first hour or months
yeah yeah day rate contract stuff yeah
that's wild yeah
and then so you did that for a couple of
years right
so i guess just on this
on the early part of your career i guess
what i always like to ask this point
just curious like what what do you think
of criminal criminals giving you that
maybe you least expected
um
good question i think for me
the opportunity to do something that i
really enjoy
that um has given me
all of the opportunities in my life
outside of work like i think it's very
rare look at some of my friends
that they haven't had the opportunities
to to move forward in their career or
potentially in the outside of work and i
think for me
i've had the opportunity through
recruitment to do all of that and do a
job that i actually really love right
yeah which is rare yeah
so rare yeah what um what what what was
they're motivated by in those early days
what was like your key competition
probably right money and competition um
yeah i'm a competitive bloke right um
and i wanted to make money and i um
i think those two when i first started
those that competition of
when i left construction was quite good
yeah and i came trusting phrase and i
was terrible really you know the
standard was just up here yeah and i
joined and i was like rock bottom i was
the worst in the office
comfortably and i think that competition
of proving that you can do it yeah that
got me through where you got it yeah
so when you so when you went to austin
fraser how long how long have you been
at af now 12 years nice so
i guess like obviously went from
construction and i'm assuming i think
when i saw your linkedin was like
infrastructure you started on something
like that yeah infrastructure so i'm
assuming that there was a different
skill set neither was it entirely
different yeah huge i mean people say oh
it was okay you were recruiting before i
had to literally forget everything
everything because
i was used to walking onto a building
site and making friends with the site
manager yeah
you know buying them donuts taking them
for a beer like all the stereotypical
things that you would associate and then
you move into a you know where you're
calling infrastructure managers and they
don't want to talk to you and you can't
use your presence and your body language
and things like that was it contract
that you went into contract okay yeah
have you
so i guess
just on that on on that journey really
quickly and obviously a lot of people
will be joining and i get this quite a
lot so a lot of people join the
recruitment industry right now who
like are building their expertise yeah
like
from everything that you've learned
right now and i'm sure you you help your
guys and girls with this now but like
what what's your advice for people that
are early on in their career that
obviously it will come with experience
with like their expertise and what they
know about the marketing stuff but
what would your advice be for someone
that's like i'm i have the right mindset
i want to learn what else can i be doing
besides speaking to candidates clients
to build up my market expertise yeah
what comes up for you on that
for me like when you join recruitment i
think one of the things that the i
suppose the bar to entry is quite low
right so a lot of people get into it i
think you have to be prepared to be shot
at right that's the way i summarize it
okay you have to be able to ask the
difficult questions
approach situations and i think if
you're if you're the kind of person that
wants to be shot at and you're happy to
put yourself out there
i think that's uh people can talk
themselves out of doing things okay um
so that's like number one piece of
advice
so what you mean by that is be willing
to ask the stupid question be willing to
maybe looked a bit silly but yeah okay
just putting yourself out there where
yeah okay i'll give you a minute there's
loads of opportunities where you go i
won't make that call i won't ask that
right right
and and you know putting yourself out
there to ring that manager again and
have that conversation it's easy to not
do it right yeah and i think i generally
believe that people are willing to be
shot out all the time are the people
that make it in recruitment quite often
because they're like cool i can dust
myself off go again learn from it um but
the people that put it off you're always
gonna struggle and i think um
hanging around with people that are
better than you
have to do that so you can take bits
from each and every one and and learn
so how
what what was that process like of like
on like you was the bottom of the pack
you had to unlearn things
like
there'll be people listening that
probably are going maybe going through
that right now i don't know like how
like how did you get through that yeah
uh great support from the people that
were managing me and understanding that
it was gonna be difficult um brutal
honesty
um
encouragement inspiration
self-reflection you know like you have
to you know i'm a big believer in like
self-talk i talk to myself all the time
yeah yeah like whether i'm playing
sports or you know my internal kind of
dialogue um self-belief
i think is really important where does
that come from yeah i don't know i i've
always been the same um
i just yeah back myself in most
situations right yeah whether that's
good for or not but um
i think you know unless you try you'll
never know and i'd always be the guy who
wants to try okay
so let's just break this down a bit then
so obviously 12 years a um austin fraser
yeah so obviously you were starting the
infrastructure piece as you were saying
like how long was it until like you then
started taking up some management
managing responsibilities and things
like that what just give us a bit of a
timeline yeah it's probably about two
and a half years before i kind of i
found my feet i was you know
contributing well and i was a good
member of the contract team and i think
um
quite quickly i wanted to to lead people
that was you know typically you know
sports i like leadership captain the
football team i kind of naturally
gravitate to that so
um two and a half years i'd say okay
so just just quickly then before we go
into the leadership piece which i'm
really keen to sort of go into detail
with you
uh from your perspective now from all of
the people that you helped supported
continue to work with now
what what do you think a like really
good contract recruiter has to master
and why
um
good question
again being prepared to be shot at
contract is hard anyone who said it's
not is hard you have to put yourself out
there over and over again because not
every business recruits contractors perm
is relatively simple every per every
company recruits perm contract is that
self belief that you may have to
get in the trenches for 12 months yeah
before you actually see any results okay
and we talk about that all the time um
so i think getting to grips with that i
think yeah being shot at um hanging
around with people that can get you
through the first period
being around people to learn from um
is really important for me because i was
speaking obviously paul sat down here
earlier and like he he was saying he he
really didn't get going he was in he was
a contract recruit and he was saying
like yeah it took him probably about 18
months yeah for it to really click
and i guess he got given the same advice
that i did which was and i'm sure you've
given this to people where it's like ben
keep doing what you're doing it will pay
off yeah so i guess my question to him
which i want to ask you was like so if
i'm someone listening right now that's
on that journey i'm in the trenches i
keep being told like
keep doing what you're doing it'll pay
off like from your perspective what are
those things they end out that i need to
keep showing up doing each day that i
hopefully will mean that i'll get to
where i i've been sort of told that i
can get to in those things
i think you need to work out what you're
good at like quite quickly for me it was
meetings right so i used to just try and
get as many meetings as possible because
then you can influence the process once
you've met someone you've got a
different relationship i think um
that's what meeting your clients and
clients just get in front of people yeah
um
and contracts whether you like it or not
it's a relentless pursuit of information
like because perm jobs are advertised
right you can find them contract jobs
you can't always find them so yeah you
need to be talking to your network you
need to be pitching managers over and
over and over again and finding out what
they do need and when they might need it
so i think if you're not prepared to
again put yourself out there gather
information relentlessly
contract's a really tough gig yeah yeah
what uh people all honestly people are
so curious about this always like i'm
sure you help people with this now what
what does this what did the typical day
plan look like yeah then at the height
of uh contract days like because
obviously i was a permanent recruiter so
i feel like whenever i sit down with a
contract recruiter like it's like it
really can be 24 7 incarnate and like it
you could get a call from that horror
manner saying ben we're we're ready to
to rock and roll and at 6 00 p.m on a
wednesday it's like [ __ ] i need to call
these contractors for the next two hours
it's like what like because honestly
that is probably the most common area
that we hear at recruitment mentors that
people want to develop want to improve
on and i think it's a continuous thing
but like yeah talk to us a bit about
what did a typical day look like that
made you feel confident you were going
to get the most out of it um again it's
i think nine times out of ten i'd
probably come into my desk without a job
because okay contract's quite quick you
get a job you fill it yeah back to
square one again yeah um
so i think for me it's again information
like if i don't have the jobs very
simply who has the contract jobs um
so was i i wasn't regimented in terms of
like i'm gonna i'm gonna do this do that
so um
i'll just be speaking to my network
wherever they interviewed you know um
i'll be trying to find out who's hiring
and all i'm doing is just trying to find
out who's got the contract jobs
and i'm going to try and find a way to
get in there and
it's just a relentless um
continuation
it's not particularly glamorous yeah
and there is no substitute for picking
the phone up on contract and having
conversations with people yeah yeah
what
what did you do because i i feel like
the same for like if you're a permanent
contract recruiter but just on this
topic of
like it really can be 24 7 like what did
you do to make sure you you didn't burn
yourself out
i look back now and i'm wondering if i
did but we probably did work probably a
little bit
longer hours when i first started when i
was trying to build that that desk um
i don't know i'm in love with the game
so i just kind of did it right yeah my
wife laughs now but
i'd be calling candidates on the sofa at
like
eight o'clock at night half nine at
night right like because in contract if
you don't take that chance someone else
will take it out that's the thing
they're so short and i think my first
ever deal
everyone was going out from the office i
got the job at about five o'clock on a
friday
and i stayed that friday found a
candidate that lived two minutes from
where the site was that the other agency
hadn't found and if i hadn't stayed i
would never have done that deal and
that's the thing when you experience
that yeah it's also a bit of a blessing
and close to next it's like right got it
done but then you're like
[ __ ] that someone else could do that so
i'm not going to let anyone go
you know it's like you're coming to you
come into your desk and you call a
candidate oh someone else has called me
and you're like
[ __ ] i should have called them last
night or so i think you learned very
very quickly yeah
so let's let's unpack this leadership
journey then because as i said before we
started i think a lot of people that
listen to this podcast will have
aspirations to become a leader
and it can be really challenging so
i guess from from what we see is like a
lot of people have the goal aspirations
to become a manager leader typically
might get there because their
performance because they're merit
and then for most people depending on
how the company works like they'll get
there and then typically won't have like
loads of support yeah
just have to
yeah be a pretty bad manager to become a
good one so like obviously i'm assuming
when you when it first started for you
like ben still had a number he was still
very much contributing and billing yeah
but then would you like mentoring
responsible for like a handful of people
as well like how did how was it like
that typical billing manager leader role
yeah absolutely the billing bidding
manager i think we've got up to a team
of six i think whilst i was still
billing yeah i think it's still the
toughest job you'll do recruitment i was
told that from day one i still firmly
believe it is um i think if you've built
some of the biggest pitfalls if you
haven't built a sustainable business
yeah if you're starting from scratch
whilst trying to run a team oh wow
that's almost impossible but i have my
client base i do a couple of deals
whilst you know
growing the team and and trying to get
them to do it as well so what would you
say like the fundamentals to like
performing in that role do you think so
obviously one of them as you said is
like to give yourself a fighting chance
is to have a have a like build yourself
a good platform sustainable business
going into that role yeah like yeah what
are some of the fundamentals because i
think obviously like what i always
typically find is i feel like it can
become really quite frustrating where
you've got a number on your back that
you need to do
but you're also trying to get the
performance up of your team you may end
up earning less money like i don't know
it's
like what would you say looking back now
the fundamentals of like trying to yeah
really perform in that role do you think
yeah i think being really clear on what
your job your responsibilities are right
i think we've talked about this before
is um
if you're just chucked a team
that's not a good place to be i think
it's being very clear around this is
your responsibility that's the manager's
job or that's the director's job
okay so you know if you work in one of
our teams it's how you do this the
manager does that that's my
responsibility give you an example um so
it could be monthly reviews okay um it
could be that's the manager's job but
the lead consultant or the team leader
you're responsible for
almost like a big brother kind of
helping the searches fielding questions
on desk um
not
managing someone nine to five but just
being there to support them and take
them through that journey and show them
and demonstrate the job
um that's good advice so because you
don't be in a position where your team
are going ben i thought i thought that's
what you were going to do i thought
that's that was your job yeah to like
really lay that out earlier what about
and i know you've done some stuff with
us on this like a really common question
we always hear is like how the hell do
you go about managing your time and
setting like
almost boundaries right because you want
you want to make your team feel like
you're there to help and you're there to
support them but at the same time you
don't want to be a manager who like
always like gives them the answers
rather than them being given the space
to like find the answers themselves you
know what i mean yeah how how can people
go about yeah just just creating those
boundaries and better managing their
time so they can perform but also give
that space to their team yeah i think it
needs to be a safe place that people
come back to you and go hey i'm
struggling or you know
i need help but i think
things like day plans evaluating the day
before being really militant with your
day plan saying what are you trying to
achieve yeah breaking sometimes breaking
up into sprints and saying hey look i
want to achieve this in the next couple
of hours cool off you go if you need me
i'm over here yeah um
let's let's review how you got on and
and doing it that way so
i think um
sitting next to someone and watching
them all day is not the answer i think
just being really clear around what that
person is looking to achieve giving them
some guidance around it and then
follow-up is the most underrated thing
in recruitment follow-up i mean if
you're not going to follow up you might
as well not bother setting the person up
in the first place so what so what you
say if me and you sit down in the
morning and you're my manager and say
right then the this is my day plan this
is what i'm aiming to achieve by the end
of the day you're saying like are you
making sure that you tie that together
by going right how did you do today i
mean there'll be
a hundred thousand recruiters that get
set up every day because it's the
manager's job but how often do they sit
down and go through like how did it go
what did you learn what do you need from
me um nice asking those key questions
how from your experience now
like
how how how many people do you think
would be like the max where you would be
like confident that like that come from
that person could do a good job do you
know what i mean yeah i know it probably
isn't a major number just curiously yeah
i think when you start getting to like
five six seven it's difficult yeah if
you're if you're running a business as
well yeah um it's difficult i think like
six seven pushing it yeah
yeah if you're listening right now and
you're a billing manager and you've got
like 10 12 ask for a [ __ ] pay right
honestly yeah yeah give me a shout out
yeah because that geez okay cool so
he's in that role then when so then when
did you then transition to like a non
billing role like yeah it's probably
about another two years down the line
where i suppose the job is to in our
business is always kind of make yourself
redundant right so okay if if you're the
doing the line share of the deals you
need to find a way to replace yourself
whether that's giving your market away
yeah you know feeding feeding people
jobs and then eventually your
contribution is a lot lower so then i
was able to kind of move out when i hit
my targets okay nice
so
just introducing your thoughts on this
and as you went on that journey
um yeah when i so i was obviously sat
down with paul before you and he's been
on like a similar journey and got to
direct on these things he really
believed that it was always good even
when he was in a director role to um
always sort of have his hands involved
in trying to to support the business by
um i don't know bringing in new logos or
like just making sure he doesn't get so
far away from that where you can't maybe
lead by example or just make sure that
he's involved in like the current
day-to-day yeah not that that would be a
lot of his time because he just felt
that was really important how because
you're just talking about about their
like making yourself redundant yeah how
do you feel about that do you think
because i think it can be quite easy for
you to like you don't want to be seen as
someone that sits in an ivory tower and
they're like there's no way i'm [ __ ]
calling that kind of client like but how
do you feel about that do you think are
you always do you think that's a good
thing to be involved in like trying to
get involved and stuff like that or do
you still i think you should understand
the business i think you should never
forget what's i'll never forget what
it's like to be a new person or to run a
desk right i think people that
forget that i think you should always be
humble around like how it is don't
forget that like um
yeah i'm not out there ringing
candidates every day but if if someone
needed me to do something i would 100 do
it and i think
i'm close to the business
the difficulty when you move out is
actually you don't want to be in you
can't tread on people's toes you can't
yeah yeah i'm sat on the desk minding my
business someone says something i want
to answer the question but it's not my
job it's the manager's job and um
otherwise i'm just undermining the
manager so actually that was a big thing
that i had to learn was to keep my mouth
shut and really let other people
like tell and coach because i don't know
i saw that right and
you can't do that hey everyone a real
quick one from me this podcast would not
be possible without our amazing podcast
partners vincerie and saucebreaker
because you listen to this podcast you
were able to get your hands on exclusive
savings on both of these award-winning
products if you're all a growing
recruitment business you have to check
out vincerie who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with sourcebreaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
sourcebreaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products so
what what would you say were the main
differences then for ben the billing
manager to bend the whatever you're
gonna call it so like i don't know what
the title would be but where you're like
not where you're like and not being you
made yourself redundant yeah what were
the main differences in maybe your
mindset your approach things how did you
have to then think about things
differently then well one of the biggest
challenges is that you go from being
able to affect stuff personally to
working through people um right and one
of the things you have to get your head
around is
if people did stuff then i wouldn't have
a job right so you can't let that
frustration creep in and you have to
accept it people and except the fact
that people don't care as much as you do
um not intentionally but they just don't
and i think when i
went on that journey i understood it i
could then be more effective but i think
when you go hands off
i remember the first couple of weeks you
sat there and you're like what am i
gonna do
like you're sitting there like clicking
like how do i affect things without
getting involved with everyone's
business
how did you end up affecting things and
what's ended up being the ways that you
end up affecting things in a positive
way well i think you get paid to make
less decisions but bigger ones right so
less of the reactive stuff and it might
be
client strategy it might be building a
solution for a client or it could be
hiring strategy that kind of stuff yeah
so you go from making loads of small
decisions every day to very few but the
impact is massive sure yeah that's
interesting
um so in terms of like some of the
things that i always like how how
important is how important is self
development been to you
um
[Music]
at the start not so much yeah because i
was just hell-bent on being a good
recruiter yeah um but it's huge now like
it's the number one thing that that i'm
interested in really yeah
like where where did that where did that
spark come from because not everyone has
that but i feel like
i'm always a bit baffled as to like why
people don't have that i don't know if
everyone
will have that i don't know like where
did that come from for you is it
something you cultivated is it
definitely i i think you get to a point
where
if you want to take a bigger job and get
better you need to develop skills right
and i think i didn't have those skills
um i think having a mentor or working in
your program
if you're not if you're serious about
self-improvement you haven't got a
mentor or you're not in a program i
think
i think that's criminal really so i've
got myself a mentor
how did you go about that in the
business no no i've got a couple
probably in the business but also
outside because um i wanted an external
personal perspective and stuff because
otherwise you institutionalized a little
bit by your company right how did you
how did you approach that people were
always curious about that like yeah how
do you do it in a way where because i
always feel like the sort of key is like
you don't want the other person to feel
like you're just you're just taking if
you get in
like ideally you want to try and
and it is hard but you want to come
across an awareness like i'm some like
that you're someone that would really
respect their time you're coachable
you're lit you'll listen and maybe this
is also something you might be able to
help them with do you know what i mean
definitely i think um
you have to ask is the first thing right
you have to ask and i think you just
have to be really honest and say look i
like what you do i really value your
perspective i'd love to spend some time
with you it's no no more difficult than
that yeah um and then i think you
develop a relationship and if they're a
good person helping people is really
important right so
no more difficult than that
so on this like leader director journey
then what what have been i think you've
sort of spoken a bit about number like
what have been some of the the biggest
challenges then that you've really had
to work through so i know you said
around
like saying less and like yeah not just
giving people the answers and those
things i don't know is there anything
else that you really had to
work on um and challenges that you had
to work on yeah like i suppose my skills
and how i influence people um is
is definitely something um
because you are you know you're trying
to take a group of people from a to b
and i think making sure everyone feels
it's fair they understand it it's
inspirational so things like
storytelling and giving people vision
and and creating opportunities like
quite difficult yeah
i don't think it's good enough to just
say hey work really hard and do deals
people were like
no like i think more than that so
yeah working on my ability to influence
people on a bigger scale um making
bigger decisions
that impact lots of people
um
how have you got better huge attachment
there like how have you got a better
understanding what people are driven by
yeah um that's hard it is and i think
you only get there if you truly care
about people but i truly care about the
people that work for me genuinely and
you know
i want to understand them i want to
understand their family life everything
and spend time with these people that
it's not talking about how many phone
calls have you made it's like cool how
are you
you know how's your family all that kind
of stuff um
just leave them with yeah and build some
trust where they feel that they can
share stuff with you yeah that's that's
a big part of it
love it what
so how how have you how have you
remained motivated in these 12 years
well i've got family which is as you
know you know um
i think everything that i kind of do is
linked directly to that like i want to
create opportunities for my family um
i feel that as a company we're on a
mission to do some some good stuff and i
think i want to be part of that i like
doing stuff that is challenging so if
i'm doing challenging work with people
that
are on the same boat on the same you
know bus as me that feels good yeah um i
don't think i could
necessarily just babysit a business like
i i need to be kind of doing something
big
what um
what how have you and then i guess on
this as well like how have you gone
about remaining
current is like i guess and like sort of
not out of touch with things out of
interest because again i know sort of
touched not really but i think sometimes
that
can happen where like
yeah like if you've been in this sort of
non-billing or leadership role for a
while where you you can sort of just
yeah lose the nuance of the the
challenges that your team are facing
day-to-day have you gone about doing
everything you can to remain current and
understand the nuances of the challenges
and challenges and those things pretty
simply i'll just ask the people doing
the job right i don't pretend to know
everything about the recruitment
industry right now i'm not at the
coalface of the business right so
um very rarely do i tell people what to
do i'll sit there and i'll almost
provide council and say like what are
your challenges what are you trying to
do have you thought about this yeah so
the people that you know the cold face
they're the people that should be
telling me
um what's going on and i'm there to help
build a solution for them so yeah yeah
yeah i just it's wrong for me to say
what's going on in the market cause i'm
not in it
so let's obviously austin fraser going
into coving i'm assuming like i have no
idea how many people you were at that
point but obviously big business yeah
so i feel like
just obviously how the challenges would
manifest in the bigger bits like that
would just just be even more difficult
yeah
how like going into this year not to go
in like the class of like work from home
pole scenario but like how how do you
feel about this sort of hybrid work from
home leading remote like how have you
found that
challenging is it taking shape yeah it's
challenging right but we told everyone
straight away like work where you want
work where you work best we just went
i think it's difficult to say you can
work here on this day so we just said
look yeah do what we need to do yeah i
suppose the
the the skill in it is to try and
provide an environment where people can
learn from home yeah but also in the
office um you know still a good uptake
in the office right but my job as a
leader is to
create an environment where people want
to come in they value it they can
collaborate but also they can
work from home if they want to and
that's on them yeah so it has been
challenging and
changing mindsets and and and
you know i never know where any of my
staff are right because that's generally
their business um
so i think
changing perception and and what the old
school you need to be in at this time
because you you hire a lot of young
people don't you yeah
it's like what are you seeing then like
do they i i feel like from the
conversations that i've had typically
most young people like leaning towards
like really like the idea of being in
the office more yeah um
and then maybe i don't know maybe i'd
like the flexibility to work from home
one or two days a week but then when i'm
speaking to a lot of companies how
they're basically deciding whether ben
hobday the recruiter can work from home
or not he's done on his experience yeah
so what i've heard a lot is like if
ben's a trainee then he's going to be in
the office for five days a week and
that's what they're owning but then as
he gets more experienced then he'll have
more flexibility like i don't know how's
that how how are you saying that because
you speak to a lot of young people and
have young people in your business yeah
i think it's difficult when you say you
can do that but you can't do that right
i feel really uncomfortable saying well
i can do it because you joined you can't
do it yeah for me i wouldn't feel
comfortable saying that um but i
understand it i think a lot of young
people my job is to make sure that if
that's what they want to do yeah which
makes sense if you've not done the job
get together and do it together that
makes perfect sense my job is to create
an environment where you can do that um
and that you don't come into the office
and you're the only one there because no
one wants to come in yeah um
but yeah what have you found young
people typically want
not to paint everyone on the same brush
but what are you doing like i think they
want to feel part of something i think
you know the people that we're hiring
they want to come into the office they
want to learn they want to see it
because a lot of time
it's blind faith in recruitment a lot of
time because you're doing something
cause someone's telling you to do it
yeah but until you see it happen
sometimes you go oh i get it now um so i
think they want to be able to
go to the gym at lunch time yeah come in
at 11 because they've got something to
do i think they want the flexibility but
they definitely want to be together so
i'm all for make the decisions that suit
you right
i think it's a social piece as well if
you think of
who your friends are today
and how many of them maybe work through
work and stuff like that you know what i
mean i think i'm like a big part of the
whole
being young and working in london and
stuff is is making those connections
yeah
maybe not through a screen you know what
i mean
um
just curious and then i want to i want
to speak to you about the because i
think um from what i've seen austin
frederick have done a lot of good things
but i know you sit on the diversity
inclusion um
board or the faculty and
the business but just curious like
what do you from your lens
like what do you think austin fraser has
done really well
that have enabled it to scale a scale in
the sense of like in the uk different
places i don't know what what comes to
mind for you which you because i'm not a
lot of recruitment companies will get to
where yeah austin fraser got to and
you've been there for a long time yeah i
think you know if you look at the
founders they're pretty inspirational
people starting in a garage you know i
think people buy into that and i think
the continual
drive to be better do more is really
inspirational when people naturally
follow it um create an opportunity for
like people like me who came in with no
experience and now i run a function yeah
we're still trying to do that with
people that we hire now so we don't
often come and hire external people in
we're trying to promote that give people
opportunity and the reason i'm still
here is literally i love it and the
opportunity is endless
i think if you give that people when you
inspire them i think people stick around
because yeah that's what i definitely
noticed is like i don't know what the
average tenure is uh austin phrase but
if you were to like go online i feel
like there's a good cluster of people
that have been there for
a while so like how how do you i think
one of the biggest challenges this year
for recruitment companies wouldn't be
attracting but also retaining
their people so like how do you feel
about retention of
recruiters like because i'm sure this is
something that is top of mind and you
think about
yeah i think if you lead with empathy
and you generally care about people you
can get in front of maybe some of the
problems if you don't care about people
you don't give a [ __ ] about them
personally and they're having a rough
time they may
leave right now we're not perfect but i
think if you generally care about people
you inspire them you give them an
opportunity that they can continually
grow and learn because i think look you
can get a job anywhere in london doing
recruitment yeah um
how you do it who you do it with what
you're marching towards these are really
important things um if you're smart
right so i think as long as you give
people that you're halfway there would
you say what are those things you said
who are you doing it with
where you're marching to i don't know
any of those do you think could like
really important over the others out of
interest
um definitely thinking knowing where
you're going yeah what what is your part
to play in the bigger picture yeah um is
really important but i think
doing a job that you you love with
people that also share same values
beliefs behaviors that's really
important um i think if you're not
comfortable there you don't buy into the
company it's going to be a very
difficult job to stick around
so talk to me about the dna piece then
um
like i think i caught up with um i quite
repeat a while ago he told me there's
some really interesting things that
you're doing
around when people apply those things
that like you can't see and like um a
lot of things are not i don't know
there's loads of different things but
like where like
what what's what's going on in like when
in those conversations at the moment on
i don't know what you call it is it like
a sort of faculty or like a charter
charter yeah so what what what have been
like the main topic of conversations and
what what what is top of mindful of you
at the moment when it comes to dna yeah
i suppose as a company that wants to
grow yeah diversity and inclusion is
paramount like diversity of thought
diversity of mind yeah like you have to
do that and we're certainly not perfect
and it's something that we we know
and we generally care about right
including pete so
i think that was uh the first part was
just to say look cool this is where we
want to get to um
getting some external help is really
important to to come and say
this is where you guys are at this is
very right giving us a plan um but the
charter really at the moment is saying
hey where are we what are we seeing what
we feeling
um
brutal honesty yeah is the first couple
were quite funny because we weren't
probably honest a lot of people i'm
honest i'd just say how i feel right
yeah but you've got juniors in there
that might not speak up so how big is
the charter i think it's about 15 16 of
us at the minute um but we will invite
more people in
but i think having those honest
conversations about as a business if
you're going to pretend it's all rosy
probably not going to get anywhere so
is it helped having like a dedicated
group of people like
driving
like i don't know driving a conversation
or that i'm assuming like that like yeah
that child is accountable and
responsible for driving initiatives
gathering how people feel about things
across the wider business has that
helped having people that could you i
think it's a great idea right regardless
how small you are as a company there
might be one or two people even if it
starts there that are like really
passionate about it that
like that no doubt other people in the
company would deem it important but
like there's probably going to be people
in your business that are going to be
better at driving it you know what i
mean so has it helped having like
that group of people definitely and
hopefully inspire other people to get
involved right and i think if it's not
important to you you're going to have a
hard time at our business because if you
want to scale to where we want to get to
unless you this is in in the forefront
of what you're trying to do i don't
think you can do it so
hopefully it'll inspire people it gets
the conversations going um
it's just a good place to start yeah
yeah yeah so what have been some of the
like initiatives that maybe have gone
well so far like what's what's been
going on
really we're at the point where we're
just finding out brutally where we are
okay um
and then we had one yesterday actually
where we were talking about experiences
sharing experiences we got follow-up to
that um pete and i have been speaking to
external providers around
coming in to help us yeah um because i
really value that external kind of piece
what is it you're looking for help with
out of interest a plan like you know
someone i think it makes sense to work
with someone who's done this before and
can give us a real
honest opinion of where we are as a
company yeah um yeah we we have
anonymized cvs and you know we're trying
to make sure that that's fair but that's
the tiny tiny part yeah if someone comes
in and doesn't feel included or yeah
they're not seeing a representation of
themselves that's a problem so i think
um
having a having a plan that everyone's
on board is is where we need to be
how what's like the typical advice you
give when like someone
is important to them they're curious
about it they want to understand more
but i think in today's society a lot of
people worry about saying the wrong
thing doing the wrong thing like
obviously a lot of it starts with
self-education yeah
so like what's your typical advice for a
recruiter listening to this that's like
you know what it's coming up more and
more in my daily conversations
personally i'm actually curious about it
it's important to me
but yeah like where do i even start yeah
you hit the nail on the head we talked
about it yesterday in the group it's
like educate yourself yeah um
it is it's hard work to inspire change
or understand it and you've got to do it
it's about action um
and i think we're all taking that we're
doing little things ourselves to try and
educate ourselves and i think that's the
first part um
and learning to hopefully you're in a
company where you can speak up or talk
to someone um
but yeah educating yourself is the the
beginning part for me nice
so as we come to the end then obviously
you've been in the game for a while yeah
like what
what what what are some of the trends
that you're seeing in the regroup
industry so
i know i've mentioned a few times but
for example um paul's in in the journey
of selling these embedded talent
solutions which seems like they put up
quite a lot i don't know if you're doing
any of that af
like yeah so like what are some of the
trends that you're seeing that you're
quite interested in or do you think
um are going to be more prominent as we
go over the next couple of years yeah
well i think the perm market is flying
everyone knows that so i think being
agile enough like we've done an embedded
model like we've got that um what's been
the learners on that i'm interested
because it sounds great yeah but
it's up from the conversation i've had
it it can be really difficult yeah
commercially it's challenging like how
you you package it up um
what you're accountable for how it works
i think it's quite challenging i think
this all these things about building
value right retainers are being sold
left right and center right and there's
great stories and bad stories about
people not delivering on them so
i think um being agile enough to to find
the right solution for that client yeah
yeah um
and i think we should be selling
contract solutions even harder because
the the war for talent is is raging
so we should be sending contract
solutions even harder now okay so we've
got so yeah different i'll get evolution
in light services what what else are you
thinking about or looking at that you're
curious about top of mind
um
the top of my mind is hiring good people
right that's that's that's off of mine
but i think um
making sure that our consultants are
embedded in the parts of the market that
we need them to be so we've been really
specific around the parts of the market
they're responsible for okay and the
kind of service they will deliver to
that
portion of the market okay um which has
led to some really great results right
yeah yeah
okay then so on that topic you said
around like
yeah really dedicated to hiring great
people
like a lot of people will be thinking
about i think that'll be yeah easily in
the top three challenges if it's not how
are we gonna go about attracting the
candidates that we know our clients need
it's gonna be how can we be attracting
talent internally yeah from the
conversation i'm having companies have
little or no success getting experienced
recruiters through the door
because yeah i think if if you're half
decent right now should be making some
good money so the sort of why behind
your move you've got already believe as
a leader and manager
so a lot of people really going back to
the sort of training on experience so
like what's
what's really worked for you guys on on
that just for advice for people like i
know there's not going to be one thing
but like
like what is t what what's typically
worked to help
you guys get more young people through
the door yeah and higher internally do
you think yeah um
understanding where you're going and
what that person's journey is because i
think again you can if someone's
interviewing at four different companies
it's the same job yeah how you do it who
you do it with how it feels yeah
they're really important make sure you
you can really articulate that yeah and
they yeah they they will have clarity on
it yeah 100 like you know um if you
can't and even if you've got experienced
people you need to be able to sell
why they should come and join you on
your mission because you could do the
job anyway you could do it yourself um
yeah
what does it mean and can you spark that
interest
i'm a massive fan of grads and
inexperienced people i didn't have that
much experience
um
you know this notion that everyone's
gone back to hiring grads well i've
always done it and some of the best
people we've got are
you know they've not even come from
sales or recruitment they've done lots
of different jobs yeah um so for me i'd
be really open-minded
and for hiring managers i mean i've got
the same list of quality skills and
behaviors that i've always used and if
people don't match them i don't hire
them yeah so be really clear on what
you're trying to hire yeah no i think
that's good advice because i think
particularly in the market right now you
you can
it could be quite easy to drop
what you're looking for can't it because
you know
you've got this guy ben could he do the
job yeah i reckon i mean we've got these
before of jobs that we can give him
straight away yeah so you could be
smashing the deals quite quickly
but for you you've you've really stuck
to your standards yeah
why is that important just because you
know how it'll play out you just know i
mean we've all i'm sure as a business
we've hired people that we think you
know they're going to come in and smash
it and look we're sales people you
should be able to sell
if you've done recruitment you're going
to be able to sell that you're good at
it i think um
for me it's it's being sure what you
want that person to do if you want
someone to come in and fill loads of
jobs then you could probably get a
delivery person to do it yeah you'll
have to pay over the odds for someone to
come in and and do that for you so
be sure what you want to hire if there's
any doubt on any of the list just don't
hire them yeah
no i think that's good advice so anyone
listening like instead of just being
like i need to get people take a step
back and
can you clearly articulate why why this
person should join your company the
journey that you're on the mission that
you're on where you're going where does
that person fit in with that plan
uh that on the business stuff right yeah
and
that that should give you a fighting
chance of
having people pick your company over the
next company where the job's going to
look very the same yeah
so to wrap up then where uh what would
your advice be for those listening to
this that absolutely won't want to smash
this year like just yeah just just
interested to hear your thoughts on like
yeah what would you what ben's advice be
for anyone that wants to absolutely have
a great year this year keep your foot
down like now now is the time to do it
um
be really open-minded with the kind of
solutions that you have to provide yeah
um
even if you've got lots of jobs keep
trying to get better ones there's better
clients you might have a hundred jobs on
your list but there are better clients
better fees keep your foot down and
just continue to go for it don't don't
coast because
things may slow down they may not but
thank you
ben it's been a pleasure
thank you mate
thank you so much for listening to the
episode i hope you got value from the
conversation and there was a number of
key takeaways so please don't forget to
like share and please do share your key
takeaways in the comments below if you
did have some and thanks for supporting
the show